salut mon grand est ce que tu vas
revenir oui oui bientôt mai
un attentat terroriste
c'est forcément un attentat surtout vous
surfez pas de vos portables si on veut
survivre à ça les gens vont mourir
c'est le début d'une guerre je veux
qu'on les élimine
c'est une mission suicide tu vas mourir
faut que je revois mon fils
éternel tu ne refusera pas tes
compassion ta bonté est ta fidélité
nous garderons toujours car demos en
nombre nous entoure ici reposent les
morts les cendres de la terre
le bien
bryant toujours du man
moi j'y crois
c'est la voix de johnny nom anglais tu
sais que c'est pas ton fils mais non
ça
uk
demain
et
en cause
ap